what's up ladies and gentlemen the Game
of Thrones community is buzzing once
again after HBO released 15 new photos
from scenes during their filming of
season 7 I apologize for not having this
video up sooner but I was actually
already in the process of uploading this
video about the long night yesterday so
I figured I would just wait and get that
one out first and give you this one
today so if you haven't watched my new
video about the long night definitely
check that out after you finish this one
alright now let's dive right into this
and see what we can come up with there
will be a good bit of spoilers talked
about here too just to let you know the
first photo was of Lyanna Mormont at
Winterfell shortly after Sita's gave her
amazing speech where she burned a couple
northerners and made it known that Jon
Snow is hurricane everyone realized she
was right and after a few quick
apologies for not helping Jon's cause
everyone started to chant King in the
North King and the north this was easily
one of my favorite scenes from last
season but not everyone was on board
with Jon Snow being King as you can see
in this photo little fingers [ __ ] ass
is still in the back sulking like a baby
obviously Littlefinger is going to be a
problem this season a problem that the
north will have to deal with and
hopefully one of the Starks will put him
out of his misery this scene should take
place in the very first episode of
season 7 the last time we were here in
this scene Jon Snow had just stood up as
they were chanting he was 13 so we will
more than likely hear Jon gives some
kind of a speech and hopefully he makes
it known that Sansa deserves some kind
of recognition as well she does
technically have the stronger claim to
Winterfell by blood this next photo is
with Daenerys Tyrion Masson de Grey
Worman Varys you can also see the
unsullied standing in formation behind
them looking at some of these facial
expressions it makes me wonder exactly
what's going on here grey worm looks
pissed and Masson day looks a little
scared or nervous but teary and Dany and
Varys all have their poker faces on we
do know that John is heading south but I
do not think this is them meeting John
here we know from set photos that tyrion
meets and greets John on the beach where
they shake hands so it wouldn't make
much sense to meet him here then meet
him again and shake hands
however I do think this is on
Dragonstone this may be them stepping
foot on Dragonstone for the first time
well not the first time for all of them
but you
know what I mean this is them more than
likely landing on Dragonstone looking at
what is now a dreadful-looking castle
Danny's dragons may even be flying over
top of Dragonstone making it look even
more grim the next photo is just a
close-up of the same photo of Tyrion I
love that he has rockin dat hand to the
queen pin which is slightly different
from the one we've seen in King's
Landing I believe the other hand of the
king pin was gold but Tyrion does look
badass
I hope Cersei gets a good look at Tyrion
again before she dies I want her to see
that he is now a boss with the support
of the largest army and three dragons
behind him I can't wait to see her
reaction when she finds out where Tyrion
has made it in life but also can't wait
to find out Tyrians reaction when he
learns that Cersei is now on the firm
after blowing up part of the city what's
then resulted in her own son suicide if
the dragon pit scene at the end of the
season is real I cannot wait to see the
look on everyone's faces when they see
everyone's new position it's going to be
really exciting intense the next photo
is the close-up of missandei she's
looking very beautiful with his new
threads and she also has a pen on her
chest but what's interesting is she was
not wearing the pen in the previous
photo if this is them arriving on
Dragonstone then she does not have this
opinion so this photo makes me think
this will be later in the season after
she received the pen obviously if you
look closely it does have three dragons
on it which is pretty cool
missandei is officially one of Danny's
best advisors and friends not to mention
she is her part-time interpreter the
next photo was a close-up of Varys it
does appear that he is standing in the
throne room on Dragonstone he is more
than likely standing next to Daenerys
as she is sitting on the forum there are
probably meeting someone here to have a
discussion or greeting someone for the
first time perhaps we could get another
scene with conveyor here that's more
wishful thinking on my behalf but if you
heard one of my collab videos we talked
about their scene before then you know
both of us wanted to hear what else can
bar has to say to Varys let's hear the
truth and not just speculation but I do
like what Varys has on though I like the
fur around the neck but now that when
air is here no one can hide from it
forever so it's cool to see everyone is
preparing for the winter this next photo
is Daenerys Targaryen standing where it
looks to be her throne world
on Dragonstone once again she looks to
be in deep thought here she also has her
hands clenched together so we may see
some emotion in this scene perhaps this
is when Jorah Mormont returns to the
merits as a cured man if you've been
watching all my videos the past few
months then you know that Jorah does
return to Daenerys on Dragonstone so I
think this might be her saying Jorah
again for the first time since she told
him to go get himself cured then return
to her because she does need him by her
side when she takes Westeros this next
photo is just badass take a good look at
the Hound here I love this photo this is
obviously the north the last time we saw
the Hound he was with the Brotherhood
without banners he was talking to
Thoreau's and beric Dondarrion he was
told that the cold winds were rising in
the real war the real threat is up in
the north the Hound does seem to have a
new purpose in life and that will be
helping John win the new war for the
dawn and I'm really hoping we get to see
the Hound stop by wonderful on his way
up north I would love for him to
interact with Sansa again or even
Brienne but what I want the most is the
reunion with Arya we know that Arya is
in Westeros heading home so I definitely
think these two characters will cross
paths again at some point if he doesn't
go to Winterfell first then he may go
straight to the wall where the cold
winds are rising the strongest he does
appear to be marching with more men than
we saw him with the last time so that
may be the case here and I'm really
looking forward to touching base with
the Hound again next season to see what
he's going to be up to speaking of
Winterfell this next photo is of Sansa
and Littlefinger it appears that they
are overlooking the little courtyard at
Winterfell
if you've seen any of my other
Littlefinger and songs of prediction
videos then you should know exactly what
I'm thinking when I saw this photo as
soon as Jon leaves for Dragonstone
that's when Littlefinger is going to be
right back and so on Jazeera preaching
that she should have control of the
north
[ __ ] Jon Snow he's just a bastard he's
only your half-brother he doesn't
deserve anything
yada-yada-yada I just hope songs his
character progresses and doesn't fall
back into little fingers traps she told
you on only a fool would trust
Littlefinger so I'd be really pissed off
if her character went back to the same
old [ __ ] again songs and now knows
little fingers ultimate goal so
hopefully she can use that as leverage
and I'll play him at his own game which
will ultimately lead to his demise this
next photo is just fantastic
that gets me even more hyped for the
prediction video that I made about a
month ago we all know by now that
torment is loving him some Brianne and
it looks like his pursuit of her
affection will not be ending at anytime
soon which is just hilarious this does
appear to be in the courtyard at
Winterfell as well perhaps this is when
Brienne and Podrick make it back from
their failed attempt to get the
blackfish to help with the battle for
Winterfell
or perhaps torment is getting ready to
leave and head north knowing he may
never make it back alive he's probably
thinking [ __ ] it let me take a crack at
this one more time before I go I know
most people want to see bran and Jamie
get together but I'm 1,000% on board
with Foreman and Breen instead and I
know I said this before but can you
imagine if bran and torment had a child
together
what type of absolute badass that kid
would grow up to be hopefully Brienne
starts to open up a little more around
torment he'll bite but anyways let's
move on to the next photo this one is a
little further up north with Mira and
bran first I just want to say can
someone give me or Reid a Medal of Honor
for what this young lady has done for
bran she went way above and beyond the
call of duty in some of the most
terrible situations to be in here she is
once again trekking north beyond the
wall more than likely dragging this
big-ass manchild through the snow in
below freezing temperatures
brain seriously needs to cut this [ __ ]
and walk already he barely stubbed his
toe when he fell from that tower now I'm
just kidding but I'm wondering where
they got another sled benjin picked them
up on his horse and took them to safety
and when he dropped them off they did
not have the sled with them still I
guess Mira is pretty resourceful but I
just thought that that was pretty
interesting I was wondering how she was
going to get him from the weirwood tree
to the wall benjin could have at least
LED mirror use his horse to take brain
to the wall then someone from the Nights
Watch could have followed her back to
benjin to drop his horse back off it
wouldn't been that big of a deal but I'm
wondering if this is brain and Mira
having to flee again I mentioned in a
previous video that maybe bran has no
choice but to go through the wall
because they were found again even if he
knows the moor could remove the magic
from the wall but I like this photo
because there are a few different things
that could be going on here they could
also be south of the wall already in
this scene I'd like to think that the
Nights Watch would get them a horse to
you
especially when Edie learns that this is
John's little brother but you never know
they could go through the same tunnel
they went through before that Sam and
Gilly showed them this next photo is
interesting too we see Sam and Gilly
both studying some of the manuscripts
and histories of Westeros and I like
Sam's new garb - Sam's definitely going
to be using his time wisely while he is
there more than likely only studying the
things that are important for him John
and saving the realm in general and also
like that Gilly is committed to the
cause - Sam has been a great man to her
and her child and he has helped teach
her how to read and she knows what is
important to helping them defeat the
others she has seen firsthand just how
dangerous they are and she lived north
of the wall and lived at Craster's keep
so she's going to ride or die with Sam
when it comes to this and I like that
about Gilly
she knows John snow - and she knows that
Sam's best friend Sam told Gilly during
the boat ride there that he needed to
help John when it was time and that's
exactly what they're going to do this
would also help explain why Sam can
figure all these things out so fast and
get back to Winterfell next season with
gillies help this is going to cut the
studying time in half
we know that woman and children aren't
allowed in the library so I'm assuming
Sam must have got their own spot to stay
or at least study in private but I'm
very anxious to see what they are able
to get from the Citadel and actually put
the use next we have Davos looking like
an absolute badass he damn near looks
like a northerner at this point and I
love that he now has his seat at the
main table here in Winterfell next to
Jon Snow Davos has always been one hell
of an advisor in a taut negotiator so he
absolutely deserves a seat there in my
opinion and I'm going to assume that
this is one of the first few episodes
into the season when Jon was named king
in the North I believe there was only
two seats at the table for him and Sansa
but now that Jon run [ __ ] he made sure
that his right-hand man had a seat next
to him - and as maybe when Jon is
addressing some of the people letting
them know that he needs to go south to
Dragonstone not only for dragon class
but apparently someone has arrived with
three really big ass dragons in a really
big ass army and everyone in this room
knows exactly what we're going to need
to do to have a chance of defeating the
night king in his army in Davos is just
the man that
with you to convince the mayor that she
needs to focus on the threat up north
more than she does that throne if she
wants to keep that throne then she's
going to have to help next we see Arya
Stark and she looks to be in some type
of tavern or in she probably stopped for
some grub and some drinks as she makes
her way up north to Winterfell so I
imagine this place is somewhere between
the twins and her home but there is one
interesting thing I think I should point
out here arya does appear to be looking
at someone and if you look at the two
men sitting behind her they're both
looking in the same direction as well so
this makes me think someone is either
speaking to the room or someone just
walked in the door that made everyone
turn their heads to look the local and
Arya's face is subtle but it makes me
think whoever is talking she knows who
that person is so it's going to be
interesting when we get this scene to
see what's going on here it would be
awesome if the hound and the Brotherhood
without banners were the ones that
walked into the room right here or even
Melisandre did hype ladies and gentlemen
let's move on though here we have Cersei
and Jaime Lannister and I must admit
they both look pretty badass here
Circe's looking fierce on the Iron
Throne and Jaime now has widow's wail
when it's hit and we know that Valyrian
steel was greatly needed in the north so
I'm still hoping that Jaime or at least
that sword gets back up north where it
belongs but this appears to be another
scene in a throne room or someone is
being greeted I think this could be them
meeting with your own Greyjoy if you've
been following my videos then you know
that your own is going to attack part of
Danny's fleet early on in the season
Euron is going to capture you're a
Greyjoy and a few of the same snakes he
then takes them to King's Landing and
drags them through the streets
more than likely working his way to
Cersei to present her a gift and
hopefully a new alliance I think this
may be what we're seeing here and it's
also interesting that Jaime is by her
side and not Qyburn or the mountain they
could just be out of frame but I'm
wondering what those two freaks are up
to I dunno I think this scene will be
during episode one next season though
because the last time we saw Jaime and
Cersei Jaime gave Cersei this look so I
doubt you go from getting someone this
look to confidently standing by their
side within the next episode this will
probably be episode 2 or 3 when you're
on arrives in King's lie
ending but that's just my guess and we
finally have John Snow King in the north
and it looks like he's down in the
crypts of 1fl ladies and gentlemen and
if you look off into the distance behind
John you can see the curvature of the
wall just like the crypts have sort of
like the shape of a tunnel and you can
also see the light glowing on the wall
behind him but there is something that
needs to be pointed out here because
people are probably thinking this is
John looking at Liana's tomb but look at
the light coming through behind him the
light glowing on the walls has a bluish
tint to it which leads me to believe
that that's the outside light coming
into the crypts entrance I don't think
John is very deep into the crypts here
and if you remember when Robert
Baratheon and Ned came down here it was
complete darkness around Leon his tomb
we know it was daylight out when Robert
and Ned came down here too because
Robert has made to take him down here
immediately
after he arrived at Winterfell so if
this was where Robert and Ned were
standing you would have seen some of
this blue light coming through as well
and if that were only a candle burning
behind John that it would have an orange
glow to it on the walls so this is more
than likely John just paying his
respects before he leaves Winterfell or
this is when Rickon is taken down there
and perhaps John is paying his respects
to Rob - John has been seen Rob since
they were young men back when Rob told
John the next time he would see him he
would be all in black I expect to hear
the stark theme song here - while John
is in the crypts making this a very
emotional scene no matter who John is
visiting down here but we're also not
even sure if Ned's bones made it back to
Winterfell either so my money would be
on to Rick on or Rob right here I do not
think we're going to get a John and Ali
on a theme together until season 8
they're going to tease and hype this up
the entire time though but John won't
find all this stuff out until the last
season unfortunately but that's just my
opinion
if you can point out something that
tells me otherwise I would absolutely
love that because I want to believe that
John finds this out as soon as possible
but that's all I got for you right now
ladies and gentlemen hopefully I added
some extra insight to these photos that
you may have not seen elsewhere hit that
like button for me please if you enjoyed
this as always I appreciate all the
support comment below and give me your
thoughts and opinions on these photos
was there anything I missed let me know
but have a good day and I'll see you
down below bye